there is a principle in the bible that
when judgment comes to a nation
the destruction returns to the ground
where the nation was dedicated to god
america was dedicated to god
on ground zero what day was it that new
york was born
september 11 9 11. so why is america
turning away from god
the last days of engineers are these
nine harbingers
signs of judgment appear in the land
warning the nation of judgment
they have now appeared on american soil
every single one of the nine harbingers
has come
to pass if somebody's listening to this
are they thinking the future looks
bright or the future looks scary
this affects the economy this affects
everything it says buildings are going
to fall down well we had it then it says
the sycamore is going to be struck down
when the last tower is coming down it
sends out a beam
strikes a tree that happens to be
growing at ground zero
it's a sycamore is it too late or we
still have a shot
are we gonna take it there's a question
the virus the riots
what's happening is all part who is
trump what role is he playing in all of
this
in the 19th year he says it will be a
blade that's a pandemic
on the land how long is it between the
first strike
on the land and the coming of the
greater shaking
add 19 years and what year does it bring
you to
2020.
so my guest today is a special guest
because i read his book back in 2012
2013 when i was at catalina island and i
got this book saying this author wrote
this book called harbinger
and he's not saying good things about
assyrians you gotta go read this book i
said you gotta be kidding me
so i ordered a book i read it um fast
forward today he's written many other
books
and uh he's got a real unique story like
myself he was also an atheist but he
went and became a
messianic jew which is a jew who
believes in jesus
and we got some interesting things to
talk about he's made a lot of different
prophecies he wrote a book in 2017
about comparing trump to almost like a
prophet maybe we'll get into that some
of you will agree some of you will not
and many other prophecies that he
validates with a lot of different
numbers and all these things and
the good news is just three days ago
harbinger two came out so we decided to
do an interview here together so with
that being said rabbi
jonathan khan thank you so much for
being a guest on valuetainment
great to be with you first time great to
be with you yes by the way
there's no i love assyrians
please make that disclaimer because i
don't want our syrian community to upset
you no no we're talking about the
ancient assyrians what
happened but we i actually have spoken
for the modern assyrian christians at
the united nations
you know syrians take things personal so
you got to be careful i know i i learned
yes they're they're taken very serious
so by the way
it's so interesting that we're doing the
interview today but something very
unique happened today today's the first
time a commercial plane
flew from israel and landed in uae
something that hasn't happened in 20
years and jared kushner
was on that flight you and i we know
this the abraham accord
you know a big deal that took place
drunk during the
uh a trump administration something that
people thought wasn't possible
why is that such a big deal to some
people that don't know a lot about this
don't follow the topic
why is that such a big deal well that
that's unprecedented i mean that has
never happened in the history of israel
i mean the last few years things are
happening i mean even relations with
saudi arabia
unimaginable in past years i mean they
wouldn't have a jewish person
from israel there ever uh these were
nations that hated israel ward against
israel
and now they're making peace you know up
kind of partly because of what's
happening in iran and to
to ally together so it's amazing and and
trump has had a part in it as well
you know so it absolutely unprecedented
and there may be
other arab nations that join in so we're
watching something
that nobody has ever seen from the
beginning of the birth of israel
so who does that benefit by the way so
if i'm living in america
and i see this on the news and they show
this oh it's such a big deal it's never
happened it's unprecedented
and i don't follow these topics i know
nothing about the history how does it
benefit me as an american
well you know if israel is is making
peace
with its neighbors that benefits really
everybody as far as they are
it also benefits you know the fact and
also actually it does benefit america
because
um you know when there's when there's
warfare there it benefits a lot of times
enemies of america
um but and on top of the fact you listen
when the bible says
when israel is blessed you know the
world is blessed so it's got to be a
good that that part's got to be a good
thing not
not that we think there's going to that
means there's going to be peace
uh all the area we know we know more
things about the bible says very clear
things about it
but it's it's an amazing thing um and
again unprecedented so
so more a world peace type of a benefit
to the world where less conflict means
you know more advancement is that kind
of the way to look at it well well it
means that
yeah well it actually it actually
marginalizes terrorism you know because
i mean this this is you know
i mean because the more you do this the
more funding for terrorism is
is taken out elite now i'm not talking
about iran or those but in the arab
world
so for the listen for the arab world
it's a great thing because
again and there's something that goes
back four thousand years called we've
talked with abraham accord the abrahamic
covenant says you bless israel
you're going to be blessed and then the
other part is also with the embassy i
mean
you you hear the story about you know
the embassy in israel was moved from tel
aviv to jerusalem by
president trump in 2019 and we keep
hearing about this again
to the average executive business owner
ceo you know person that's running their
own company
you hear this why is this also a big
deal that this
is happening during trump these are two
different items that are taking place
why is it such a big deal to go from tel
aviv to jerusalem well there has there
has
never been in all the history of israel
there has never been
any major power that has recognized
jerusalem in fact to find
to find any parallel you have to go back
to ancient times
even to the days of king cyrus in persia
you know because that the last time you
had a major a major
uh leader world leader recognizing
jerusalem
that's persia that that goes back in the
bible so this was major and you know the
bible speaks about in
in israel that jerusalem is going to be
the center of conflict well
that's part of it but also that that
nations which says nations will try to
move jerusalem like the status well
that's part of it but also it says that
israel will rebuild that temple so
all these things play a part in that and
trump i mean
i wrote a book where i you know this is
the book that just came out but the last
book i did
called the oracle goes into the
mysteries behind all these things and
the thing is that
that trump you know one of his one of
the things that he follows i mean in in
that
we have we and we can go wherever you
want but in the paradigm he follows a
man there's a
pattern a man called jehu but but that's
for america and there's a lot to it
but for for israel he said he's osiris
you know which is the persian king who
recognized jerusalem
but cyrus you know it's amazing because
when you look at trump
and you look at the time when the first
resolution
concerning israel and jerusalem was
voted on by the u.n
this is in 1940 1947 on the hebrew
calendar and you
you the bible says 70 years it talks
about a 70-year period
it says after 70 years cyrus issued this
thing
well if you take that date and you go on
the hebrew calendar
to 70 years and and it says after so the
day after
it's the exact date that trump issued
the jerusalem declaration exact day
and is that what you wrote about in the
book paradigm in 2017
that's in the oracle that's in the
oracle the authors of the mysteries of
israel the mystery i mean amazing stuff
that's happening and trump
is in there the paradigm is speaking it
speaks about the
the the uh jehu jezebel and all these
people in america that has to do with it
with america
and and trump and all this stuff that's
happening so how about before we get
into that
um you know that was very helpful to
give you a perspective and by the way
for somebody that's watching this
harbinger didn't just do okay i mean
harbinger sold a few million copies and
it was on the
new york times best seller list i
believe 100 consecutive weeks
and it was constantly being talked about
so before getting into some of your
ideas i think it's important for the
viewers to kind of know your background
so what is your story for you to go from
being an atheist to wanting to become a
messianic you know jew yourself how did
that process take place
yeah well well i'm raised you know i'm
here i'm doing this here now in
from with you in my office from new
jersey i was raised in new york not
not so far away um raised in a jewish
home my father escaped the holocaust
from germany
um raised in a scientific home you know
both my parents are scientists
um and when i was about uh eight years
old
you know i i had gone to the hebrew
school but you know i heard about god
but when i was eight years old i said
i didn't see god's presence in the
hebrew school i didn't see the god of
the bible who was real and moving in
people's lives in the in
the synagogue so i became an atheist and
and when i was about 12
or 13 around 12 i started seeking i said
well atheism doesn't work there's got to
be something more than that
that means it's got to be a cause to our
existence and so
i started seeking everything i could i
started getting books on
science religion ufos you know
everything
one day i pick up a book i thought it
was a ufo book and it was a book called
the late great planet earth by hal
lindsey
it was all about how biblical prophecy
what was spoken of in the bible
thousands of years ago is coming true
now with a rebirth of israel the
gathering of israel and all these other
things i had no idea
and so that turned my mind and you know
intellectually i said whoa i can't argue
with that
and then i saw then as i'm as i'm
reading i saw how the
how the hebrew scriptures the bible that
we had we had the old testament
it prophesies a a a messiah who's going
to come and die for our sins i thought
that was catholic
said what's it doing in our bible he's
going to write he's going to be born in
bethlehem i thought that was catholic
it's in our bible
he's going to ride in a donkey into
jerusalem that's in our bible
there's only one person and that's jesus
so i started believing in my head
that about just because i couldn't argue
with it but i didn't want to live it you
know i had a rock band i had all this
stuff and i said you know what
god if you give i don't want to give
this up so if you give me a long life i
will accept you
when i'm on my deathbed and about to die
so that was my deal
and then right after i did that i was
almost killed
twice i was the second time i'm crossing
a train track
it's at night and there's a i look and
there's a light it's the train
i thought that you know because people
had been killed at this intersection
and there was no protection i had no
idea i said you know maybe i'm a little
too close so let me just back up and now
there's headlights in back of me i back
up though about a foot but i thought i'm
just being extra careful
i'm waiting for the train but i'm in the
path of the train the train comes
it plows into the car i'm in a ford
pinto which used to blow up on on impact
but it goes up like aluminum foil the
only thing i could do was call out to
god i called out
lord god you know and the car was
destroyed
and i didn't get a scratch so i said
lord
i said can we renegotiate so as i said
we have a new deal here i'll accept you
now
when when i turned 20. just don't kill
me until then
and so on my 20th birthday it was like a
man who had it was like a business it
was like a man who had a contract
i said okay lord i i don't know how to
get saved but i know how to come to the
lord but i found him i said
in the hebrew school i remember
mountains moses was on a mountain elijah
so i said let me find a mountain i found
a mountain went up to the top kneeled
down on the top of the mountain
and gave my life to the lord so you know
the bible says jews
require a sign well i required a
locomotive train
but i'm the least likely person
to being a believer so you are now a
believer
total so how did it go from there
to you writing all these books and
specifically let's start off with a
harbinger because that's the one that
had a lot of momentum and people around
the world were reading and talking about
it all the time
yeah well well i've been a pastor or a
messianic rabbi for years you know
up here in new jersey about about 20
minutes from new york city
called the jerusalem center above israel
um and i always you know i was seeing
things when 9 11 happened i saw a lot of
things and
but i wasn't ever gonna i didn't i
didn't plan to write a book but
what happened was i'm standing at the
corner of ground zero
and i'm looking and i see a tr i see a
tree and something tells me
there's something about that tree and
you have to seek it out there's a
mystery
and yeah so i started i started seeking
in the bible and and that mystery turns
out that that one
that tree was the first puzzle piece of
a there's another puzzle piece an
ancient mystery
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger so i was blown away and that was
the that began the harbinger and then i
shared it at the congregation
everybody's blown away
and then everybody said you gotta you
gotta let get this gotta get this out to
the to america
but i didn't do anything but a little
while late finally a time came god said
write a book so i wrote the i wrote a
book i wrote the harbinger
i put it in a story even though it's all
real i have a prophet telling
another man these things um and uh it is
opening up the
really the signs of judgment that
that have that that what came on the on
ancient israel in the last days of
engineers are these nine harbingers
signs of judgment appear in the land
warning the nation of judgment
they have now appeared on american soil
every one of them and specific erie as
you know you
you read it um some in new york some in
washington some involving
uh national leaders some in involving
ceremonies but they
all have happened and that is the
beginning of the mystery
you might you mind getting into a few of
these with us assume the audience hasn't
because i know harbinger two's coming uh
is out three days ago
yeah so if you want to go through the
nine i have them right here in front of
me if you need a reminder i'm sure you
know it
sure sure no yeah okay the the the
ultimate thing it centers on a scripture
that's in isaiah isaiah 9 10.
isaiah's recording what's going on and
the first
the first sign classic sign of a nation
in danger of judgment being warned of
judgment is that a strike
comes on the land by an an enemy and it
is
limited it is it is contained but it's a
wake-up call it's a shaking
and and it's to call the nation back it
god only allows it when it gets so
desperately called the nation back
uh but if the nation doesn't come back
then certain things happen so what
happened is isaiah writes isaiah 9 10 it
says
the people of israel you know attack
comes on the land
and the people of israel instead of
coming back to god
they defy god and they say we're going
to come back stronger without you we
don't need you
so they say something they say about
they say the bricks have fallen
in the attack the buildings came down
but we will rebuild with
with with you know quarried stone we're
coming back we're gonna build backs
bigger
the the sycamore has been cut down in
the attack that
but we will plant cedars or an erez tree
in hebrew a bigger tree a stronger tree
in his way in other words we're coming
back god
we don't need you we're not repenting
we're going to defy you so here they're
being warned of judgment
and the defying god well we had it it
came to america
on 9 11. we had our attack but the ama
behind
all this was an ancient mystery in every
one
of these harbingers i'll give you an
example it says first of all it says the
bricks of all so it's
saying that the enemy's going to come
come to the land
and the bricks are going to fall
buildings are going to fall down well we
had it you know we had we had the world
trade center fell down
then it says the sycamore is going to be
struck down well what happened on 9 11
on 9 11 when the last tower is coming
down it sends out a beam strikes
a a tree that happens to be growing at
ground zero
it's a sycamore the biblical tree struck
down
on that and then it says we will plant
cedars in its place or we'll plant an
eras tree in hebrew well the people of
new york
they decide they're going to plant
another tree in place of
the fallen sycamore and the tree they
plant they have a big ceremony
is the same biblical tree that isaiah
speaks of another sign of judgment
it says that the people of israel or the
leaders are going to say
that vow the bricks of fallen well well
well the day after 9 11
america is going to make it stand its
statement and they the congress gathers
on capitol hill and that the man who's
responsible to give the
statement is a guy named tom daschle
senate majority
he gets up gives the speech and then he
says he says there's a word
a scripture from about from isaiah that
speaks to us now
and and out of his mouth comes the
ancient
declaration that that was said by the
ancient leaders of ancient israel that
brought judgment
comes from his mouth he says the bricks
have fallen
but we will rebuild with you and stone
the the the tree is
he word for word he has no idea what
he's saying but he's pronouncing
judgment on on america linking it
to the nation that's under judgment he
has no idea there actually is a sycamore
tree that
he says it he he says we're gonna plant
this he has no idea they're gonna do it
three years later
he said you know everything he says and
he says that is what we will do so
literally prophetic and by the way he's
not the only one it happens three years
later
on 9 11 of god the man running for vice
president john edwards
on 9 11 he bases his entire speech on
isaiah 9 10
having no idea what he's doing and again
and again even obama is part of the
mystery
um so every single one of the nine
harbingers
has come to pass i'll mention i'll
mention
one more and that and by the way this
affects the economy
this affects everything because actually
911 caused a crash and there's a whole
thing called the
shmita another mystery that affects wall
street but let me just tell i'll tell
one more
from this and that is this there is a
principle in the bible
of judgment that when judgment comes to
a nation
that the destruction returns to the
ground
where the nation was dedicated to god
now america was dedicated to god
on its first day as a nation it was a
day that george washington is sworn
in as president and actually he gives a
prophetic warning on that day
well what's going to happen if we ever
turn away from god well where and then
they
he goes to a church they all dedicate
the government praise and they dedicate
america's future to god
where was it because we can find that we
can find the ground
it was not it was in the capital but the
capital wasn't washington it wasn't
it wasn't philadelphia the capital the
first capital of america was new york
city
where in the southern part where
america was dedicated to god on ground
zero the destruction returns to the
ground of consecration this is a
biblical sign as much as any of them and
on that day
on that day when 9 11 came a shock wave
goes forth
from ground zero and it strikes the
place where washington was standing when
he
when he was sworn in and he gave a
prophetic warning said what's gonna
happen if you ever turn away from god
god's
blessings are gonna be removed and it
splits the the ground it actually puts a
crack in that ground so
that you know all the signs have
converged together but
all that and i just gave a piece of it
but all that
is just the beginning of the mystery i
always knew there was going to be more
and there was going to be a sequel
because this was the beginning
so what you just talked about right now
is harbinger two no that was harbinger
one
that's what okay so that's harbinger now
now going to harbinger two what what is
talked about in harbinger two that's
different than harbinger one
oh everything well well here's the thing
okay i knew
well okay when i wrote this a few things
one
is i could only put some things in that
book because
what i put in that book in the harbinger
is is a p
there's a piece of of much more that i
could not
speak about because there was too much
and it wasn't the time that's number one
so i always do obviously there's gonna
be more
number two when the harbinger okay when
i wrote the book
and and more things happened it hasn't
stopped so
more harbingers have appeared in the
land because we have continued on this
this mystery of judgment america has
been falling going away from god and so
the more harm injuries i have appeared
from then
up to this day that's number two so the
so the harbinger too is going to reveal
number one what i didn't reveal
that from back then but still effect
it's affecting us now number two what
has happened since and number three
what is happening right now and where
what the shaking that's on the land
there's some there there's a there's a
mystery behind it are we approaching
judgment
are we in danger and how much time what
time do we have and what are we to do
and what's the hope
and what do all of his people what do we
need to know
for the future so the harvard two is for
this moment i'll tell you this
because you know i for years i said i
can't write this book i can't write
because it's got to be the right time
and about one year ago i'm praying to
god i'm saying lord what's the next book
and i get this which i didn't want i get
this because i wasn't ready for that
and the harbinger too but the thing is
that but also i got that this year 2020.
now this is before the year came
was going to be a year of shaking
shaking
on this year and and i even told people
uh publicly i said it's going to
shaking dark events but there's a
purpose in it so
so i knew it was going to be the
resuming of the harbinger that mystery
is going to resume and i had to write
this book
this year because when i look back at
the harbinger i haven't
by the way i'm and i'm not doing it and
promoted i'm on i have a desk here
but for those who don't know this is
what the heart the original harbinger
looks like
this is the harbinger that's what you
read you know and this is
you can see it back there but this is
the harbinger too so the so the thing is
that
that i look back at the original book
and there there actually is a chapter
called things to come and it talks about
the pattern of judgment and we're in it
it's coming true because
it talks about there's going to be
there's going to be years of time a
window of time for america to come back
but then they're going to be shakings
that are going to come up on the land
and it talks about what kind of
shaking's gonna come it's happening now
it also talks it each actually pinpoints
the time
and the year that it's gonna come and if
we have time i think we will because
you're generous with your time
i'll show i'll talk you i'll show how
exactly this pinpoints where we are
right now we want to hear about it tell
us
well the only thing is it's going to
lead right up to i mean
we'll lead to it the only things do you
want do you want to do we only open up
the
mysteries that have not been revealed
and what's happened since and then get
to hear
sure sure yeah okay let me give you let
me give an idea
of that you know and you and i'm glad
listen when i do an interview i'm not
always doing an interview with someone
who's actually read
you know read like the harbinger so i'm
very blessed uh here
first thing there are some things that i
didn't reveal back then there is
something
where when judgment begins comes on a
nation what you see a pattern in the
bible that
god that the judgment strikes the powers
of the nation
strikes the economic power strikes its
military power
well america's economic power and also
god brings it back to the foundation
america's economic power
has been centered per year you know in
the history of america new york city has
been the powerhouse financial
trade you know economic industry new
york
so when did new york begin when did this
rise begin because it happened a long
time ago
when did it start rising well it started
rising when henry hudson sailed up the
river and he found manhattan
what day was it that new york was born
september 11
9 11. america's rise
to economic super began on 9 11. long
before it was a day of calamity it was
already the foundation day of america
that is the biblical mystery that
everything goes back to the foundation
the warning is if america doesn't come
back to god
if it doesn't turn back from where it's
going its economic
power is going to crumble and the thing
is that we are you know
the what happened on 9 11 is almost a
foreshadow of something bigger
so now now let me tell you another one
with that their other power
is of course the military power so when
did america really rise to
your global military power well it
happened very suddenly i mean america
was always isolationist going back and
forth but it finally happened world war
ii
america entered the war in 1941 and from
then on
it was over it became the superpower
military superpower of the of the
of the world and what what happened at
the same moment
that it was rising it built a building
that would represent that rise and that
building of course is the pentagon
on 9 11 not only does everything return
to it the economic power and you know we
have the trade center that's economic
and
and it comes to the place where america
rise began on the day
but it also came back to the pentagon
and military power
and the thing is but when did the
pentagon begin you know they had a you
know they were dedicated they broke the
ground on the potomac river
on what day september 11th
the pentagon was built began on sept on
september 11th
so long before we knew 9 11 as this day
of you know calamity it was the
foundation day
and that's why it happened on that day
and the warning is
god's saying listen all the blessings
you have have come
come from god you know and you can't hit
war against god if you keep doing this
even your military superpower even that
will crumble and we're and i'll i'm
going to tell you you know
something that i i you know that is
really some it kind of foreshadowed it
before it all happened
on 9 11. well actually just before 9 11
came there are appointed words
from the bible that are appointed from
ancient times
to be read on specific days and what
happens is all around and this is an
ancient thing
i mean jesus opened up the scrolls on a
certain day all around the world
the jewish people open up their scrolls
and they do the appointment they read
the important word they recite it they
chant it in their synagogue
well certainly it was happening in in
new york city because you have a lot of
jews so
up just before 9 11 happened there was
an appointed word they opened up the
scrolls and what was it
it was the word from the bible that says
it's called
israel but you now can apply to america
and says i'm gonna
if you follow me i'll bless you i'll
make you i'll bless you economically
i'll bless you militarily i'll bless you
in every way but
if you turn away from me this is what's
gonna happen
and what it says is this an enemy will
come
from far away he will come from far away
and he will strike you
at your gate actually the gate of
america's new york city will strike you
at the gate
it says that in the middle of it it says
there will be a rain of dust upon you
now
now there's a lot of things that that
means back then but ameri on 9 11 a
reign of dust came upon new york city
it says the it says the below you your
your ground shall be iron and your sky
will become lebron will be a copper or
bronze
well that can mean a lot of things but
on 9 11 literally ground zero
was made up of steel and alloy of iron
and then
on top there was this cloud all over new
york and filling the cloud was copper
and and it goes on and on and says the
enemy will come
like an eagle in other words he'll come
from the sky he'll come like an eagle
and the hebrew says he'll come as an
eagle swooping down
and that's one of the signs actually
every plane of 911 came in his eagles
moving down that's one of the signs
of judgment in the bible an eagles
moving down the first plane that came
in and struck began 911 on the back was
an
image of an eagle swooping down that's
the image of judgment in the bible
and that's the same this the the plane
that struck the pentagon had the same
marking on it
and now this is down what i'm telling
you now and again i'm speaking to
someone who
who read the harbingers is this was not
in the harbinger because
this is all it's all this was so much
but this is what's coming true we are
now in a great a great shaking which i
well we'll get to it and that but let me
i'll tell you one more
and this is just a sample of the part
that's called the unrevealed there's
much more
but another one is this there is a uh an
ancient warning of alarm you know and
in the bible and you know this well
because you know you know the bible and
that is that the watchmen would sound
the trumpet like if he saw
an enemy coming on the line so the sound
of the trumpet and i
i probably have one in this room but uh
it's the ramshorn the shofar so they
sounded it yeah and it would
an enemy was coming on to attack the
city
well the amazing thing that people don't
know is that
all around the northeast on the morning
of 9 11 before the pentagon knew before
anybody knew
the sound of god the sound of the
warning from the bible starts sounding
the sound of actually sound of judgment
and enemy attack all over and and it
starts
actually because it was appointed from
ancient times for that morning
but not only that it starts where the
terrorists are the first
the first trumpet starts sounding in
maine that's where the first terrorists
were
and just as they're coming then it
starts sounding in boston
and they're they start coming to boston
then it starts sounding in new york city
they come to new york city
then it starts sounding in washington dc
all according to an ancient mystery and
the the trumpets are are appointed to
sound until
about 10 30 on that morning well the lat
they're sounding when everything's
happened on 9 11 the trumpets were
sounding
all the even before and during but then
they stopped
when do they they stopped about 10 30.
the last
event of 9 11 is the fall of the north
tower it happens at about 10
29 and then it's all over the trumpets
are the warnings of god and and to say
this i believe you know what an
interesting because when i wrote the
harmony with
arbiter 2 it ends talking about the
trumpets god is sending a warning right
now
and the harbinger 2 is a warning what we
need to know right now
but is a warning of the trumpet america
hasn't been listening but we're being
shaken now but
that's a little taste what i just gave
you is a little taste
of some of the mysteries that i could
not touch from back then
but they're about ultimately now well
let's talk about a couple different
things here before we go into uh
harbinger two
uh what other countries would you say
made their foundation like what the
country was founded on
was founded on a judeo-christian
religion what other countries would you
say
well that's a that's a great question
because you know
on one hand you know one hand america is
very unique
in that it wasn't you know the foundings
were the puritans you know
and they came purely to to found it for
god's glory
so there's a very so in one sense you
could say that
of all the nations in the world there
are there's two nations that are joined
together in a very
very interesting way and one is is
ancient israel and the other is america
which was actually founded by the
original appearance to be another israel
another israel and actually warned and
there's a whole mystery here i won't go
into now but it comes up in the
harbinger too
but that is linked to a warning that was
given at the very beginning of america
that's coming true now
linked to that but but uh but then you
could look in another sense
there have been nations you know western
civilization
has a foundation that is judeo-christian
now even though it's gone away
you know so in the other sense you could
say that western civilization
has a foundation of this so if it goes
away
if you know it it's going to follow
these patterns of israel's fall well
america is
is kind of like the epitome of it
because it's following the
exactly what israel did and it's it's
it's witnessing the exact signs of
judgment that israel did
um you know but within western
civilization you have it generally
a general foundation with america you
have a very specific one
so and and here's the other thing and
now here's the i'm going from you know
specific
to gigantic on the other sense western
civilization has pretty much affected
the
whole world so really in another sense
the whole world's involved when
when 9 11 happened you know to america
it affected the whole world
and and the harbinger too you know what
i'm talking about what's coming now
what's happening and what's coming um is
it these things are for the entire world
these things are going to affect the
entire world
entire world so the reason why i'm
asking this question is the following
reason
so for me uh if
if we choose to start a country okay if
we choose to start a country
and i always like to have this
conversation is what are
things we have to do to attract the
right people to the country okay so if
you want family people
what are parents gonna want the country
to have one is security right then you
can go into
all these other reasons but typically
first one is security then you sit there
and say
if you were to start a country are you
more ben is it beneficial
to start the country with no religion
meaning there is
no religion just do the right things
values principles
you know don't mistreat people don't
steal don't commit crime
you know any of this stuff that you have
but no religion
or is it better to have a religion then
if it is to better have a religion as a
foundation of a country what religion is
best
to have as a religion to start a country
and
that that's why i'm asking that question
from him when i said is there another
country that has a judeo-christian
foundation
and if it does who is it and how
successful were they
yeah well the it's it's the west it's
got to be in the west i mean as far as
you know with christianity
and the west has been the most
successful it's interesting that you
said that
because i mean america has been the most
successful nation you know up to this
time
you know and actually you know and
actually you know you
well at the very foundation of america's
uh beginning
it was prophesied to america that is a
man named john winthrop you know they
we say george washington is the father
of the country and and george washington
interesting is linked to ground zero and
and giving a prophetic warning
but there's another person who's called
the grandfather and that's john winthrop
and he came with he was the leader of
the puritans who came to massachusetts
and he founded that and he gave a
warning and
and he said well he gave a promise first
he said
if you if we will follow god follow the
ways of god as
in ancient israel we'll follow the ways
of god we will become
the most lifted up nation in your people
in the world
god you know our enemies will fear us we
will be prosperous god will be with us
as he was with israel
if we do that you know and and that's
exactly what happens we shall be
a city on a hill remember people reagan
and others talk about america city on
hill
it comes from here i mean ultimately
from jesus but it comes from here we'll
be sitting up he's but people miss what
else he said
he said but if we then turn away from
that foundation
if we then turn away from our god then
the judgments that came upon ancient
israel will start coming upon the land
of america
and that is the harbinger and that in
fact
you know and not to the harbinger it's
what's happening now i mean it's going
off that
and all that everything i talked
everything we talked about were the
judges of israel coming upon us
but that but the other thing about that
is that that
winthrop when he said that it's a famous
message he said that warning
he's quoting from moses who's talking
about what will happen if you turn away
from god
and that's the same scripture that was
read that
that ushered in 9 11. it's the same
thing that he spoke i mean it's amazing
but
yeah so this all this all comes together
so so
here's the reason why i'm asking the
question so there's it's fair to say
other
other nations have judeo-christian as
their foundation there's many other
nations who believe
in god and who have christianity as
their main foundation
why has america has been more prosperous
than other nations who have also had
a christianity as their main religion
why has america gone so much more is it
because their economical system the
constitution
the federalist paper the declaration of
independence or is it because of god
what is the reason
that's a that is a great question well
first of all okay
first of all i would say i mean the
first part is that interesting because
the west again has been the most
successful to the world
you know in general by far it's not even
close it's by far
yeah yeah and then you have but then you
have america so
but it's it now there's a lot of things
people can say about america look at
this this we have freedom of course you
know but
the thing that separate america was from
the beginning was that was the
was the the foundation that we are here
for god we're not just here for
for race we're not here for for conquest
we're here for god we're to be a city on
a hill
and that has been from america from the
beginning and you know it's become
secularized but still
that has informed america from the
beginning but the so that's there but
the other thing about america which is
different from europe i mean
the closest thing we've got is great
britain you know that's close to america
and that was also blessed you know many
ways
but but the reason is that that often
throughout europe
you have it's christianity became more
cultural in other words
i'm born a christian i'm born there i'm
born a catholic border protestant
and so that became a thing that was also
under the state it was joined to the
state
in america it was never that way in
america
it was never hey i'm a christian just
because of culture or this
it's that it was passionately we're
going to follow god and it's not based
on the state it's not based on we're
gonna follow god regardless
um and it's not a it's not an
institutional thing it's not this and so
america has
always been you know the other those
other nations were not founded by
puritans or by pilgrims they're not
founded by people who are saying the
most important thing in our life
is jesus is is our faith and we're going
to do we're going to serve him no matter
what
we don't care where we are we're going
to so that is the ultimate thing it is
the
answer is it is god and one of the and
one of the signs of it
and it's not that there aren't other
factors but it is god that's what makes
america different and the other thing is
that
the fact that there actually was a
prophecy given by one of those puritans
about that we were going to become
the most successful i mean it all bears
that out before it happened
it was already there so so why if that's
the case
why does because the debate then becomes
the following if
if god favors america more than other
nations
why does he favor america more than
other other nations
that be the biggest question i have why
is it i mean there's other places that
have this
why is america getting a bigger favor
than others yeah and it's not that it's
not that
yeah yeah it's not that he you know he
favoring the sense that i'm
i'm on your side and i'm against the
others but they bring in that if you're
if you follow what i say you're going to
be blessed so
america has number one i mean it was
founded
purely i mean from the beginning
gigantically i'm talking before the
declaration
was founded on the foundation of god
number one number two
and by the way you see that in not only
in italian then
when you look at the constitutions of
each state each colony it's all saying
we're doing this
we're here for the glory of jesus every
virtually or every one of them
is saying that but then then america
also has spread the gospel
to the world more than any other nation
in the past as for that so god says i'm
gonna you can do my will i'm gonna bless
you i mean it's fallen but that's what
it did
number three god said four thousand
years ago
to abraham i will bless those who bless
you
yeah i will bless you abraham and
talking about abraham's family he
repeats it
to to his descendants i will bless those
who bless you
those nations that bless the jewish
people israel are going to be blessed
that is a law of god from the bible and
it has held true
from the time of egypt to the time of
america
every nation that has blessed israel
jewish people has been blessed
every nation that has cursed israel in
the end is cursed
one way i mean that you might have a
little lag time but it's going to happen
and i can tell you
you know example after example after
example from the spanish empire to the
british empire
to the roman empire and and the and when
those nations that curse israel says
what
will be cursed and and i'll i'll just
i'll mention this just one thing here
and i can do a whole thing of this when
britain
blessed the jewish people and blessed
them with you know with coming to
britain
as and giving them escape and blessing
them with the land of israel
the british empire was lifted up to the
height of its power
then it then between the wars it turned
against them it started started blocking
ships coming turn against them
what happened to the british empire like
a like an umbrella it collapsed
it like 10-year collapse and what was
the nation that rose in its place
america and what was america doing
saying we're blessing you so you've got
all these things you've got and listen
all of it's the bible the bible's true
one you've got the foundation you know
and since also righteousness exalts a
nation
you know you got two you got the the god
the spreading of the gospel
three you have the blessing of israel
the jewish people no nation has blessed
israel the jewish people more than
america
no nation has been more blessed but if
it turns away from all these things
the blessings are going to be removed so
why is america turning away from god
good great that's the that's the
ultimate question well
interesting okay why is america turning
away from god
is the big this is the big issue right
now first of all one of the things in
the bible you look at the pattern you
know
israel's in trouble they call out to god
god blesses them
then they start getting prosperous god
blesses them and then a lot of times
they start forgetting
the god who gave them all the blessings
because they got lost in the blessing
and forgot god well
that's the danger america has gone off
and blessed more than in
any nation but it's easy to forget god
that's what's happened
secondly we are in this mystery
following
the the the same template of ancient
israel what happened after 9 11 i we
share the beginning that was the
beginning and that's why i had to write
the harbinger to now
is that it was just the beginning
because what happened is is that it
wasn't just that an attack
a warning came on the land but the p it
was the response of the people which was
defiant
well america has followed ever since 9
has fought instead of coming back to god
has been racing away from god
and it's been more you know it's raced
away since 9 11 more than before
then even before it's accelerated and
that is exactly
what happened to ancient israel when it
was warned instead of getting better and
coming back you'd think that would
happen
they got worse and they started defying
him and so god says okay
judgment is going to come he says i'm
calling you and god still gave them a
window of time saying come back come
back come back
but they didn't so we are the the the
thing is that it's
not just the signs of the harbinger it's
that america itself
has been following the footsteps of
ancient israel so we're following this
mystery
unfortunately and then it leads to you
know since the harbinger
you know i wrote the harbinger in in uh
about eight years ago
and but it has never stopped it has
never stopped
and more harbingers have appeared it has
not you know and so
and and that's one of the things that
the new book opens up that we
it has continued to this day are we at a
point of no return meaning
america can no longer return to god
because of what woodrow wilson did when
we became more
secular and you know bible was taken out
of schools and no more prayers and
you know we have to uh be careful when
you're taking out the
uh uh uh under god and all these things
so we're stepping away from it is it too
late or we still have a shot
that okay every question is like the
question of the hour
is there a chance people ask me is there
hope you know and and in the harbinger
too
i do at the end as you go there i go
into what the hope is there is a hope
are we going to take it is the question
um the
if i looked you know if i if i looked at
just the way it's going i'd say i don't
i don't see hope
the way it's going as far as turning
back on the other hand i know with god
there's always hope and the other thing
is that
if we follow the biblical pattern it's
heading a certain way
a very definitive way and all these
shakings that have come upon us now
they're part of the mystery but the
thing is that is their hope
interesting the way you phrased it you
said have we passed the point of no
return
interesting because i've been caught i'm
calling for
and this is i think it's important that
we say it uh and this is coming up
if if this airs before it's coming up in
the month of september september 26th
but even if it airs after
you can still take part in a way um it's
called the return so you said until we
passed the point of no return
it's called the return it's going to be
in washington dc it's a gathering to
come before god
and for the turning back of america and
pray and seek his face and repent
uh god's people to come to the
washington to the washington mall the
national mall
september we say it's open to everybody
i'll just pull this in because it's
important
nobody's getting anything out of it it's
for america um we're going to come
together with leaders from all over and
everybody's welcome uh but it starts in
the morning 9 a.m
uh the national mall by the washington
monument and it's going to be
the whole day uh but and a very
important day but if you can't make it
you can do it in your home you can do it
with your church you can do it in a
field it's going to be simulcast and
streamed all over the world so
but but so that that is the reason for
that is it's a call to what you
asked for is that can we return yes we
can
but are we going to we shall see my
sense is and i'll i'll get into why but
my sense is that
that the shakings that we are now
experiencing are
it's not over and they're going to be
greater things coming and i believe also
this period
is a very critical period this this this
autumn as we head to the election
very critical and that but can't you
people ask me is there going to be
do you see judgment calamity or revival
and my answer is
for a long time is that you know what
there could be both in fact there can be
shakes sometimes revival will only come
out of shaking it could be that america
has grown so hard
so deafened to the voice of god that it
takes him shouting like he is right now
and it takes shaking for us to come back
and it's actually
as c.s lewis said it's the mercy it's
the severe mercy of god
that he's that he does that cs lewis a
whole different story but you know can i
be a devil's advocate with you real
quick can i be a doubles advocate you're
okay doing that
yeah let's uh let's uh uh let's let's uh
have some fun with this because our
audience is
50 50. you know we got some uh who are
and some who are not and i always want
to be able to give both sides so we can
kind of uh
uh process this for ourselves so so you
know
when i sit there and i debate any topic
i always debate it
as if i'm on the other side not as if
i'm on this side because if i can win
the debate of being on the other side
i have an edge over my whoever it is
whatever topic it is that i'm debating
so is it fair to say that people were
more naive and
uneducated 2000 years ago they didn't
have access to books
mainly the powerful people had access to
books and a lot of times
we had a lot of deceptive and divisive
emperors who took advantage of people
and
used fear tactics to get them to do
certain things that they didn't want to
do
and you've seen many stories you've seen
the book of eli where
in the book of eli it's hey keep the
book away from everybody but if i get
the bible i can control a nation so you
you know this
i'm preaching to the choir here yeah
however as we're getting smarter
and as we're getting access to more
books and we have access to more content
and information
and people are kind of coming out and
you're saying i was speaking at an event
in newport beach
and there was a room filled with pastors
and we were talking about why
tight tithing and got you know
and offerings have gone down you know
people are not giving the kind of money
they used to give christian church is
not getting the kind of money used to
get i think the only one that is growing
at a pretty good rate is the mormon
church but not
not all of them not a lot of christian
churches growing and getting more money
than they did before
so is it more the fact that people are
starting to say
i think there is god i don't know if
this is i'm going to be more of an
agnostic you know what i don't know if
there's really a god and i'm just
starting to read more and these fear
tactics don't work on me anymore
and i'm being a little bit more logical
and i'm reading the books and i'm
getting more educated and i'm no longer
being able to use with fear tactics or
is there really
something that's happened in america
right now where people are stepping away
from it because america is becoming more
and more successful because you know
this when
a nation or a family or an individual
experiences more success they give less
credit to god
and they tend to want to take more
credit because there's this deep
desire internally for a lot of a man who
are competitive to eventually become a
god so
what are your thoughts about what i just
said right now okay
i went all over the place but i'm
curious to know what you're going to say
to it come on okay
all right first is versus is there you
know was it because they didn't know as
much then and we know more so that's why
we are
yeah and i i will i'll say very strongly
first of all
they it doesn't matter you know that's i
think that's kind of a pride of our age
you know
um we don't first of all you know you
look at the people
of the bible uh did they did mary know
any less than a woman today that you
don't have a you don't have a baby
without
without without a man of course of
course not do they know
any more less than we do now that you
don't rise from a tomb no they knew that
just as much so
they knew they weren't saying that you
know this is this is first of all
you know they knew as much as we do
about how life works okay
in some cases maybe more um secondly
they've actually done studies and
they've seen
intelligence going down because with all
the computers they're doing our thinking
for us
so not necessarily the other thing is
that that what
what touched me and well let me let me
get to the king's part
uh kings weren't you know back then it
was you know anybody can try to use
anything i mean
but the the big power of the gospel is
the opposite it actually overturns
kingdoms it actually sets slave three it
actually
caused the roman empire to collapse it
actually it actually speaks for freedom
it actually caused america to come into
being
uh from an old world of oppression it
speaks freedom so
so no actually the gospel is
revolutionary the true gospel is
revolutionary
um the other thing is that that you know
i told you that
i was an atheist for a number of years
you know and and it's
it's kind of like maybe they could say a
little knowledge you become an atheist
but a lot of knowledge
you become a believer because when you
get to a certain way just like cs lewis
which you mentioned
uh or we both mentioned cs lewis you
know kind of became an atheist but then
when he he went deeper
he realized this doesn't work at all so
the thing is that what what took me is
that even if you you could have all the
super computers in the world
you cannot scientists today cannot even
tell you what's going to happen in the
world two years down the line because
human events are too intricate
but the bible you got a fig tree farmer
or
a shepherd and he's speaking two and a
half thousand years ago
and he's telling you what's going to
happen well only god could do that
so in all our pride we've actually
become dumb the bible says
professing to become wise they became
they became
fools and so that kind of you know it
goes along with what we both said
that on one hand when you have you know
when you have kind of prosperity you
have wealth it's easy to kind of forget
your need for god
in the same way when you have a little
bit of knowledge it's easy to think oh i
got this i don't need that
but when you get to the end of that it
comes to nothing and the end of it so
no the answer is uh you know actually
the the the gospel is spread more in
our modern age than any other age in the
history of mankind well i mean sure you
could say that exponentially because
there's also more people today than ever
before
mankind but i'm just i'm just you got to
realize i have this debate
all the time and when i'm sitting with
folks having these debates and we go
back and forth as a guy that's a math
guy
i'm always curious you know what your
perspective was going to be there and
there's a lot of people that may say
well back then
if you try to use the story of virgin
mary today
people would say come on i don't know
about that maybe 75
000 youtube videos and facebook videos
made going viral
but back then it was kind of like okay
if people believe it i will as well
don't you think yeah no that that that's
very important because
because that that's on a total uh
false assumption that that again that
people
any that back then they had any other
idea that you don't you you could have a
baby without a man just doesn't happen
that's why you know in the bible that's
why it's real that's why it's not a myth
it's reality
because when mary was told this she
didn't say oh okay
you know magic she said how can i be it
this doesn't work you need a man for
that
okay when they saw when you know when
that when when
when jesus messiah rose from death
you know they didn't say oh okay i guess
you could just do that no they were
shocked they fainted they were they ran
they knew this thing this doesn't go
they knew as much about nature and
probably more
because they lived it they were more
connected to it than we do
so it's based on a totally false
assumption
the p you know you got somebody like
paul who was a brilliant
for like philosophical uh rabbi you know
he knew all those things so
no if the answer is no if you were you
know you're you know if you're going
dealing with mythology the bible
is the anti-mythology it's saying this
happened here
up in time and space and here we are you
know back then it says
back then it was jesus and now it's 2000
years later and guess what
the entire world still still revolves
around and we still date everything by
this one
jewish carpenter he still said your
kingdoms rise and fall yet the name of
jesus
is still is still above all things you
cannot stop it you know and that's
exactly what it is but then again it
said the jewish people are going to be
scattered to the ends of the earth
and they're going to be persecuted in
every nation and then in the end god's
going to gather them back
they're going to come back to israel
back to jerusalem the nations are going
to come against them
they're tell me about technology tell me
about how your technology could
come up with that this is from simple
these simple people
spoke uh with more wisdom than all our
collective technology
in the world to this day only god could
do that
there you go so i mean if somebody's by
the way uh c.s lewis one of the better
stories out there
to go through i don't know i'm sure
you've seen shadowlands with anthony
hopkins
yeah the movie a phenomenal movie and uh
c.s lewis somebody that i i like to read
a lot about because
uh not just mere christianity he's got a
lot of different things that kind of
takes a perspective of
a different perspective but now let's
talk about harbinger two so if you want
to kind of bring us home with harbinger
two what things
what things are in harbinger too that we
ought to be uh we ought to be thinking
about
yeah well everything that i've spoken
about about those things that
you know from the mysteries that were
not revealed to the word that was
pointed to the alarm that was all that's
only in harbinger too that was never
revealed before that
but let me i'll give you a little taste
of what's happened
since okay i mean and let me actually
let me throw this in because when i
wrote the harbinger
i had no idea about this you know i told
you about that scripture that you
you kind of were reminding me of it was
isaiah 9 10. you know that breaks up
wall that's the harbinger of scripture
but here's what i didn't know on the day
of
9 11 be again before the pentagon before
everybody
all around america believers christians
are opening up their bibles
to isaiah 9 10 the harbinger scripture
the scripture that talks about the
beginning of the attack the beginning of
judgment enemy attack before it happened
why there's a bible called the one year
bible
it's all around america and every day
it's got an appointed scripture
if you go to the one year bible and you
open up to the harvard scripture isaiah
9 10
beginning of judgment attack on the land
you'll have you'll see a date above it
the date on that page is september 11th
the the one-year bible came out before 9
11 it came out in the 1980s
and it linked together the day of the
attack and of the beginning of judgment
as being 911
of being and every year on 9 11
believers were opening up their bible
to the harbinger scripture about the
attack on the land on 9 11
years before it happened now there's no
that you talk about let's talk to our
friends our doubting friends about that
how do you put that together but now let
me tell you
a little taste of what happened i'll
i'll i can only give you a taste because
there's so much there but i'll give you
a taste of
in the next section about what's
happened since i'll give you an example
there is uh and this is gonna this is
gonna touch on some hot stuff
but we have to we have to do that uh
there is a
day in the bible that is the day that
judgment kind of broke through the day
that the enemies
of israel babylon broke the walls of
jerusalem broke the defensive walls the
protective walls once they did that
it's over but they broke the walls of
that day the day is called
the ninth of tammuz in the in the
biblical town ninth
of tamu's day of mourning day of because
all the defenses broke down and judgment
came
a number of years ago the supreme court
um
uh struck down the biblical
definition of marriage we all know it
they did that
it was on june 26 2015. but on the
bible's calendar
it was the 9th of tammuz the day that
you strike down the walls
that are protecting that civilization
marriages
so on the day they had no idea on the
day
it was struck down this happened after i
wrote the harbinger
and now in the harbinger i spoke about
those nine harbingers that we spoke
about
one of them we said was that that tree
that they
that they put up they planted the erez
tree or you know
on the place of where the sycamore was
that that's in the bible and that's in
the harbinger as well
and so here's the thing that tree was
one of the harbingers there's a tree of
defined say we're going to come back
with a strong tree it represents america
eres tree this
this they call it the tree of hope at
ground zero but here's the thing
in the bible it speaks about judgment on
the nation it gives a sign it says
the the tree shall wither away
what happened to that tree of hope that
you read about in the harbinger
it started to wither away representing
america started withering away
like a nation withering in spiritually
withering morally
with whatever they tried to do they
couldn't stop it all around
it on ground zero all the trees are
blossoming the tree that tree that
harbinger is withering away
then president obama and this is not
about you know not about politics but he
comes down to ground zero
and he actually reads a scripture but he
changes the word of the scripture
the scripture says says god will break
the bow you know in other words the bow
and hour he'll break the weapon and
bring peace
not blessing on the nation he changes it
and he says god will break the bow which
is not the po
it's it's a it's a branch that's a sign
of judgment
in the bible now i'm sure he didn't know
what he was doing but the white house
changed the word in writing
and it's a sign of when god says i will
break the branch you know
well they started breaking the right
across the street is the tree it's that
tree
that he they start they start breaking
off the branches because it's withering
and then the final sign is the
aerostream in the bible it talks about
great judgment coming a fall of a nation
is when that when this tree you see it
as cedar in the bible but it's the
aristocracy strong tree
it will come down crashing down well the
tree of hope was an heiress tree
it cut it came crashing down it fell
it was destroyed and it was destroyed on
a biblical holy day
and uh and and the thing is that you
know if the sycamore tree
is linked to 9 11 the fall of this tr
the heiress tree is linked to that means
that it's a greater
thing coming a greater judgment coming
and i'll i'll i'll just give you a taste
of one more of what's happened since and
then we'll get to right where we are
one of them is called the in the in the
harbinger 2 is called the image
in the last days of ancient israel the
god takes the prophet jeremiah
and he takes them he takes them to the
temple and he says look what do you see
son of man
he says i saw an image i see an image it
was it was a it was an image of a false
god
and god says and look at that now
because of that you're going to have
judgment on this land
well one of the signs of a nation in
judgment is that
the appearance of images and other gods
in the land now america will never admit
that we're following other gods you know
but once you take god out that's what
you're doing
but could this sign have appeared of a
god of a god
an image well it happened in between
after i wrote the harbinger in new york
city
an image a giant colossal image of a god
of a foreign god
came up on over new york city they
projected the image of the god on the
empire state building
the the god it was the largest foreign
god
false god in the history of the planet
as far as i know on earth
the head alone was 300 feet and it was
the god
kali it's like she's it's the god of
darkness
so here they're using light to create
the god of darkness the bible says in
isaiah what are those who call evil good
and good evil
and put light for darkness and and on
that day
on that day actually it was it was soon
after america struck down marriage
on that day it was a saturday so that
was the day that there's an appointed
word to be read
in the city across you know across the
world but in new york city
from ancient times and what was the word
that was appointed when america put up
the image
the word was god's saying do not
make an image of a god because
you will be bringing judgment do not
make an image so they put the image up
and it's the kali is also the god of
death
and destruction and it's over new york
city
and that's just a little taste and i
will tell you this
as i i mentioned at the beginning when
we first started
but i will now i will i will tell i will
gladly all those who are watching
i will i will tell you how but actually
what's happening right now
is all was all foretold in the harbinger
and is all according to the mystery in
the bible of where we are
so if somebody's listening to this
are they thinking the future looks
bright
but the future looks scary well i i
would say this
if you are not if your life
is not in god if it's not in the will of
god
i'd be afraid if your life is in god
i would not be afraid because because
there could be great revival and god
god will bless though and god god if
you're with god you don't have to fear
anything
you know but but if you're not with god
listen even if i wasn't telling you this
you should fear because
there's no hope without him and so the
call is if you're not in god
listen his arms are open come come but
it's not religion
it's you must be born again is what
jesus said that's what he's saying it
doesn't matter who you're listening i'm
talking to you
i'm a jewish i'm jewish i'm a former
atheist uh
my my good host is will come coming from
persia
and you were an atheist and he and
you've come to the lord and none of us
were expecting it i don't think
i you know i wasn't i wasn't expecting
it but it says if you seek you will find
you know so god is saying he said you
didn't say you have to be religious he
said you must be born again
and and what i'm telling you is where we
are right now
this is all part of the mystery what the
the virus
the the the riots what's happening is
all part of it
who is trump in all of this right now i
know you've spoken about trump comparing
him to cyrus the great you've spoken
about
trump comparing him to uh uh king uh uh
i want to pronounce it right
jihu uh uh uh yeah so you you
who is trump uh what role is he playing
in all of this
okay yeah to america now this is and
we we were speaking just before the show
this is in this is in
uh another book i did called the
paradigm i mean i mean it's related to
the harbinger too
but it's the paradigm the paradigm is
showing that it's not only the signs
that are replaying but the
people are replaying that meaning
that behind the leaders of israel are
behind the leaders of our time
there are they're following the
prototype of ancient leaders so it's not
just
it's not just the signs it's the people
our son and trump is one of them
what happens is we won't be able to go
through
all that but but you can get the the
paradigm anywhere and
we can talk anytime but every leader
from clinton
you know bill clinton to hillary clinton
to barack obama
to trump all that every single one
follows it like clockwork and not just
the people
but the time that they're going to be on
the national stage exactly
so what i'll just i'll put it this way
from the paradigm
there's a moment when when israel is
about is really ready to
to seal its fall away from god and what
you have in power
you have you have behind the scenes is a
woman named jezebel
jezebel is is is part of the house
her she was the wife of the king ahab
but now he's not king anymore but she's
still
behind the scenes of power well and this
is not about a person we gotta pray for
all people love all people but
this is gonna match hillary clinton and
and
and i'm not saying that because i have
anything about hillary clinton there are
people who say this because they do
but the fact is she's gonna follow this
exactly um and
and she is there and what it comes down
to is the nation's about to
is that a crossroad and and it's either
going to follow the house of
hillary clinton or spouse of jezebel or
or something's going to happen
so what happens is at that moment when
it looks like jezebel
and her house is going to reign forever
uh
god raises up a man called jehu jehu is
a warrior
he's a fighter he's not a politician
well donald trump is not a is a fighter
uh jehu is impulsive he just you can't
predict them he does this does that
so is donald trump uh jehu jehu begins
a race to the throne and he gets on his
chariot begins a race now
now now donald trump began a race to the
presidency a guy
in the bible is watching jay who comes
watching the charity
who is it he said well i don't know but
it's he drives like jehu because he
drives kind of like like
like he's crazy well the race of donald
trump to the white house was crazy
but the thing is that what happens is
jehu
then it comes down to a com a
confrontation between
jehu the warrior and and the
and jezebel the former first lady and so
you have in america
the warrior trump jehu and you have the
former first lady
of america hillary clinton and when you
and the one and everybody said you know
hillary's clinton's going to win he's
going to wipe out
but the bible said that when they come
together
hillary oh j the jezebel's going to fall
and jehu is going to rise to power and
that's exactly what happened
and i'll there's so much but let me tell
you this about this
jezebel was in was on the national stage
for 22 years 22 years
with her husband ahab
and on her own after her husband's reign
was over
14 years well jezebel well that's isabel
hillary clinton was on the national
stage from the moment that her husband
became governor of arkansas
to the end of his presidency how many
years was it 22 years
how many years was she on her own she
retired for public life for two years
came back
all together 14 years exactly
as at exactly exactly so you've got
donald trump then
but the importance of donald trump it's
not about trump doesn't matter what you
think about him
because jehu was was wild but
god raised up uh jehu at to
to give the nation a little bit more
time
to hold back you know what actually we
can see it happened to hold back
this this wave that was going to seal
the nation's fall and
end and begin persecution and end the
gospel you hold back so donald trump
gave up reprieves not about donald trump
not saying he he's not reading this
okay but but he he's doing that so
and this matches up with what we just
said in the harbinger too this is part
of the window of time well donald trump
was an extension of that
but now we're coming to a crucial moment
that's why all these things are coming
to a head
all these things and the virus and
the economic collapse and the lockdown
and the the the unrest is all part of
the biblical mystery
began in the harbinger from the bible
and is is resuming now and that's why i
knew
i had to write the harbinger too because
we're we're in it right now
very interesting i can tell you that
it's very interesting to listen since i
know there's a lot of people out there
that'll say well
you know even a broken clock is right
twice a day and some of these prophecies
you can kind of say
you know you can match them in different
stories to say well this is how it
matches with this what do you say to
some that say
come on rabbi khan some of these things
are just you know ironic
and they're just kind of a you know we
can match some stories to match with it
today
what do you say to those i'd say you
read the book and you won't say that
read the paradigm there's no way you're
going to say that i have atheists who
read the book and say whoa
whoa i have people you know any of this
you know i first gave this to a a jewish
person who's not a believer
it was not a believer you know uh you
know she was the lord and she said
this can this be true she went on the
web and started looking it up no
we're not talking about some some
general things saying okay we're gonna
have hard times we're talking about
exactly when i you know i gave you i
mean when we talk about this you know
this is not about tom daschle saying so
he's quoting the exact
verse there's an exact exact sick form
there there's an exact day the date of 9
11. actually i'll tell you
in the paradigm that when you when you
look at this template from the paradigm
this is the
other one it's actually going to
pinpoint if you knew this mystery back
then
you could have actually pinpointed the
exact day that 9 11 would happen
i mean the exact day years before if no
this is not general
this is exact i'll give you and i'll
give you example
from the new book you know one of the
one of the questions that you know what
is it what happened then is it coming
true what i wrote in the harbinger
well there's a there's a this you know
this is now listen this is before the
fact
there's a there's a chapter in the heart
your original book
called things to come and things to come
it says here's the template
the strike comes on the land then you
have the window of time years
then if the nation doesn't turn back
it's gonna the
shakings are gonna start coming on the
nation it's
what kind of shakings does it say and
you can anybody can look for themselves
it's in here
but what kind of shakings it says the
judgment [ __ ] will come
number one you'll have you'll have the
dividing of the nation
the nation will be divided well we've
never been so divided as now
you will have disorder civil disorder
you got it now you will have economic
you know collapsing we've seen that you
will have
it says uh the breakdown of
infrastructure we're watching all
almost infrastructure breakdown all with
a lockdown with a virus with a right
all over us but then it goes through
some other things that i believe are
gonna happen
that that's there but then it says i
actually use the word when i'm talking
this is this is eight years ago when i'm
talking about what's going to come i use
the word
crown the crown the crown you know the
word crown is in latin the word is
corona
you know that now now now let me tell
you this
what about the timing there is a mystery
in the new book
you know i don't usually hold up books
like this but but
but we're talking about different books
now so the harbinger two where it talks
about it's called the 19-year mystery
and here's the thing
the question is asked how long not
general specific how long is it
between the first strike on the land in
this template
in the biblical government and the
coming of the greater shakings
well it gives an answer in the harbinger
and one of those answers is in the
kingdom of the ancient kingdom of israel
judah it says the first strike came by
nebuchadnezzar
in 605 bc that's when he first attacked
it but it wasn't destroyed
but then the the the greater judgment
says shakings came
in 586 bc so when how long is it
19 years 19-year mystery the bible says
in the 19th year
this happened 19 years again and again
again so
when was the first strike with america
it was
september 11 2001.
add 19 years and what year does it bring
you to
to the year that will be the year of
shaking
2020. is the year is the 19th year
2020 and this is not by the way for
years
after i wrote the harbinger i'm looking
at this i'm saying lord
god is 20 20. this is all points of
2020.
is 2020 going to be the year of shakings
of dark events of calamities now that
was already there
now now as we were approaching this year
i was led
and not just that i was led deep in my
my spirit to tell people publicly
but i believe that this was going to be
the year of these things
well it's happened not only that i mean
now listen
there are even signs because look at
look at the the first thing
the disease the plague what's what's the
name of the plague we said crown corona
what number 19 19
the number of judgment i'm not now now
did they come up with that for that
reason no
but that they don't need to it doesn't
matter but it's not only that
but the prophet jeremiah the prophet
jeremiah he prophesied of what was going
to happen
in the 19th year and what did he say and
one of the things he said was going to
happen this is about israel but but now
the pattern
in the 19th year he says a there will be
a plague a peasant what is that that's a
disease on the land that's a
pandemic on the land so even that
is all was all there in the mystery and
it's coming true right now
and we're we're it's not over i think
that's the way we go home i mean that's
that that's how we wrap it up that that
that was uh i'm a math guy those numbers
really make you think it's crazy to be
thinking about all those 19s
by the way let's do a quick speed run
i'll give you a name tell me the first
thing that comes to your mind
uh uh so whenever you're ready this is a
fun game here trump
trump oh my trump what comes to me is
trump because he's a trumpet
he's a blasting trumpet and it's a time
of warning
assyrians i better say good i'm going to
say good
but the old bed a lot better now the
syrians
a lot better now than they were then
okay that's fair joel osteen
nice guy i don't want to say more safe
creflo oh my goodness oh my goodness
oh my goodness i i want to say focus on
the i mean i'm telling
people by saying focus on the gospel
focus on the guns
uh uh biden was prosperity what was it
what was it okay yeah
biden weak
kenneth copeland uh
um oh my goodness um um
i met him he's a really nice guy you
know but but you know a really nice guy
i don't you know
keep going okay hillary clinton
i think i think i okay all right listen
it's not personal but jezebel
wow okay listen it's not personal but
i get it i mean it's you wrote about it
in 2017 it makes sense
yeah uh uh prophet muhammad
false jesus the answer
the answer how about we finish on that
well yeah rabbi
can i say good just just a quick thing
but
but there is hope i will tell you that
and there is hope but if it's okay i'll
just tell them
to get the to get the harbinger too it's
available everywhere i'll just say you
get on amazon online
walmart everywhere you'll get if you
have people in your life who who are not
who need to be woken up
believers or unbelievers it doesn't
matter if you're not a believer check it
out
and if you want to come to the return or
be part just go to the return.org but
let's pray because these are critical
times we're going to put a link to both
of them below with that being said rabbi
khan thank you so much for your time
thank you i appreciate you god bless you
as well
so lots of prophecies do you agree with
them on all the different math and the
19 what are your thoughts comment below
i want to hear your thoughts
and on top of that if you enjoyed
today's interview i think you will enjoy
my sit down with
dennis prager if you haven't watched it
we got heated in a couple places of it
if you've not seen this one click here
to go watch the interview with dennis
prager
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody
take care bye